i wanted to get into you know you made
the documentary the plot against the
president talking about russiagate and i
felt like we just needed a little bit
more context before just jumping into it
but i want to start with this article
here because this one's going to make
your blood boil it's really fast
from the philadelphia inquirer the
impeachment of president biden and other
american nightmares coming in 2023 by
will bunch
with polls gerrymandering making a gop
house all but inevitable in 2023
americans need to ponder a year that
could tear the nation apart i love
the the obliviousness the ignorance was
it not a nightmare over the past five
years dealing with the incessant lies
from the media with adam schiff lying on
tv with us being lied to over and over
and over again and gaslight and they
impeached trump twice
i love it in his in his scenario he's
like it's a great chilly washington dc
day in march 2023 you know they're
convening to impeach joe biden and wears
it he says like uh a code pink protester
bursts onto the floor and screams why
are you doing this are these people
insane why are you doing it i'll tell
you why we're doing it because joe biden
colluded with ukraine to stop yes funds
from going to ukraine to stop an
investigation of barisma because the
prosecutor in ukraine was investigating
brisbane where hunter biden was on the
board as well as a cia former cia
director i believe was a director and
the us and joe biden had interest in
making money in my opinion i'll tell you
what i think the u.s wanted a gas
pipeline for the cutter turkey pipeline
going up through syria and a turkey they
wanted they wanted to to compete with
the russian gazprom natural gas monopoly
and i think joe biden said hey if the
u.s wants to do this we get in the
company i put my son on the board and i
get 10 percent for the big guy when the
prosecutor started investigating michael
zlatchevsky the founder of the company
joe biden comes in and says if you want
the billion dollars in the federal
government you better fire the
prosecutor and then the president did
and victor shoken signed a sworn effort
david saying i was fired for
investigating a company where joe
biden's son worked
then they had the nerve to try and
impeach trump over that absolutely and
that's not even including what's going
on in china i say break it up the whole
system is rotten to the core if you
remember when i first came on this show
about a year ago
and a couple months one of the first
things i said we need a peaceful divorce
because it will lead to the least amount
of human harm but essentially what we're
doing right now i i think we're going to
be stronger if we're going to be
decentralized because this centralized
corrupted system is literally weighing
everyone down when biden announced there
was no federal solution to covet a lot
of people were like that's awesome
that's great finally let people do what
they want we already live under this
kind of system where states get to
decide what they want to do themselves
empowering them even more allows more
representation allows more
independent voices to be heard and
allows people not to be corrupted
whether in ukraine whether in china
within any other international dealing
whether it's saudi arabia there's so
much corruption it's rotten to its core
it's disgusting it needs to break up
immediately at this at this point what
we are okay i i i hate saying this but
uh the united states is a corrupting
i
say it i kind of can't it's that hard
it's a corrupting force in a lot of
these places look i didn't know one
thing however i'm gonna go back to
ukraine okay because that's easier okay
i can talk about ukraine ukraine was the
corruption playground of our elite and
it has been for many many years and no
one's been willing to pay attention to
it because because why because it's
boring because most people aren't that
interested in foreign policy and they're
not that interested in all this stuff
but so the reason why that impeachment
and that the the vin men's the whole the
whole thing i mean fiona hill my god all
of this popped up is because you have to
understand this was this little little
and this is this is what this is what
the intelligence services have done to
our country our country which which
accidentally i mean not accidentally but
but by by by uh uh by pure sort of god's
grace and uh um and and
and and and triumph we became a
superpower okay after world war ii i
mean and and there's this thing i talk
about recently which is
we're not ready for what that's what
it's what it's like to not be that
that's right okay like we don't like
most of us don't have any idea what it's
like to live in a normal country okay
where you're allowed to just do whatever
you want and your intelligence community
can just sort of run around and like it
so so it makes me very very angry and
obviously again the reason i say this
over and over again is because it's not
it's not it's not that i i make my
you know my my uh my my deal online
every day and everything i say is i'm
always crapping on the
ic and the fbi and everything else it's
not because i i like don't like them or
something i'm like i'm like specific
like i had some reason to wake up one
day and not like them it's because i
actually care about those institutions
it's because i need them to work right
so let's go back to ukraine for one
second
look uh the reason the ukraine is such a
big deal is because this was this was
the this was the like wild west for the
corruption of the united states and uh
we we saw that again the tip of the
iceberg in the joe biden stuff in the
hunter biden stuff this is this is
normal for these people this is this is
what it's for like and and this poor
country which i i again i have no reason
to like dislike the ukraine i mean but
that's what they were they were our
center of play they were a playground
for our elite okay
and and the one thing that i want to
make clear which is is something that i
i think hasn't has has been sort of
forgotten out of all this
again obviously as the director and uh
producer of
clearly the the anti-russia gate movie
right the movie that proves russia gay
wrong um all of that all of that is
actually quite true the the the my
feelings about russia on on the on the
world stage all of that has remained the
same the one thing okay that they could
have done wrong the one thing that our
foreign policy elite that hold
themselves so high
russia was never our biggest enemy it
never ever ever was like russia not
since the fall of this okay right right
not since then russia was absolutely uh
emasculated on the world stage it was it
was it it's very bizarre the way we
treated russia when you look at it
versus japan
we could go into that for two hours the
point is the one thing you could do to
make russia dangerous and and and i i
don't i don't stay up at night worrying
about russia but the one thing you could
do to make russia dangerous is give it
an ally like china and that is all that
they've done that's all they've done
they've given it they've given it the
they've given it the the resources
they've given china the natural
resources of russia they've they've
they've literally created it together
yes but i mean it's it's it's uh it's
it's
it's very similar to how i used to see
the middle east so i could talk about
this forever but i won't well i want to
i want to i want to make a point about
where we're going politically sure so
with
the fears now that joe biden's going to
be impeached even though we went through
two trump impeachments what this guy
writes for the enquirer is we are going
to see a revenge-based 118th congress
that will spend most of its time on
benghazi style hearings blah blah blah
blah good
good hold on it's not benghazi style
hearings but no no it's not revenge
it's not retribution but it's justice
remember that word benghazi style
hearings so
what we're dealing with now like like
once about things that actually happen
that can then get brushed under the rug
so for five years we get lies
endless hearings manipulation
adam schiff nancy pelosi lying about
everything it's not revenge it's justice
yeah the republicans need to go in
assuming people vote in the primaries
and get rid of the rhino establishment
neocons they're not going to and they
need to to actually vote this stuff out
have we got who've we got who we got
tell me who we've got look remember no
let's not let's not get uh
yes that one would be nice um he's just
one guy what do you think of rand rand
paul i don't know let's talk about joe
kent some more okay um no sorry that's
just awful well so that's you're
pessimistic on this you don't know i'm
not pessimistic at all i'll talk about
joe ken all day um anyways no mm-hmm
anyway you're saying we're not gonna get
republicans no let's just get back to it
i've okay all right we've got uh
crap all these guys are my friends now
so i got to be careful uh
well one thing that's terrible is that
we just lost nunes which is as you know
from seeing my film uh the one person i
think maybe the one politician in the
entire world that i ever really trusted
like with i mean trusted to tell the
truth no matter what like no matter what
the guy had nothing to gain from what he
did and he he solved russiagate he did
the whole thing you know you've had cash
hotel on the show uh nunez put out that
he brought the early report it's not
just that he was lying his entire his
entire career i mean he he
there's nothing as i said politicians
care about more than their uh uh
popularity amongst the whatever
there's no one who took themselves down
more willingly for the truth than devin
nunes i mean i don't know integrity like
that i've never even met it before
that's why i wanted to make a movie
about it i mean but so he's out he
retired yes he will be out and he will
be doing great things on the outside and
i'm very excited to see uh what how all
that goes anyways uh the okay so who
else we got we got okay look i like jim
jordan a lot jim jordan's done some very
interesting things the freedom caucus
has done some very interesting things
but what i am concerned about is people
who uh do very good sound bites uh
during hearings
and they can their their comms teams can
make very nice little clips out of those
sound bites and they can sound very
tough and da da da but what does it
actually accomplish
we we need we need the behind-the-scenes
killers that might not be as good at the
sound bites and that's fine and that's
that's when okay so one thing i will say
you need to you need control of congress
and it needs to be among actual
populists and anti-establishment
individuals we need we need the whole
takeover this is why i mean i might i
might make a joke out of it because i'm
i'm silly sometimes and i'm like a
little bit of a goof but like you know i
at my uh my caucus i've invented make
congress hot again yeah sure okay but
it's also america first it's very very
very much america first it's we must
have this new class of congressmen we
have to because we're entering into the
post-trump era okay and it's tough for
me to say that look i'm uh obviously a
a trump kool-aid drinker as i've said
like we gotta drink the kool-aid i'm in
fine let's go drink it i'm good i'm i'm
in i am so in and i work in the
administration and i would do anything
for this president i do i do i do
anything for this movement okay but
that's what it is it's a movement all
right it's uh
we got to figure out what that is and
and there's there's uh there's certain
people trying very hard to figure out
what that means but at the end of the
day we do we have no time to lose like
none okay we gotta get this new class of
congressmen in we gotta get this new
class of senators in and and we gotta
act like now uh because that means
voting in the primary yeah and and and
and i think americans know that i feel i
get the so like i i don't get to travel
into the normal states as much as i used
to i do travel sadly all the time but
it's it's not always to the places where
i'd like to talk to people where i used
to be able to like get down and like
hang out and like talk to like normal
people but like i hope they know i hope
they know what we're up against we are
we are we are this is it guys thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time